I want to bring you
now some exclusive new CNN
reporting about
one of the federal investigation.
CNN is now learning for the first time
what top Trump officials have told
a federal grand jury
about an effort by the
then president
to seize voting machines
as part of his scheme
to steal the 2020 election.
CNN National Security Report
is echoing here to join the conversation.
So lay this out.
You have exclusive reporting.
Ken Cuccinelli, a top official
at the Department of Homeland
Security, Chad Wolf,
who I believe at
the time was his boss
at the Department of Homeland Security,
testifying to a federal grand jury
about being involved in meetings
where Trump wants to seize
voting machines. What do we know?
John, that's right.
Multiple top
national security officials
that served in the Trump
administration have gone
into the grand jury
and testified in recent months
and talked a lot
about how they had conversations
directly with Trump himself and said,
look, DHS,
the military,
they don't have the authority
to seize voting machines
and they had to repeat that message
not just to Trump,
but to his lawyers,
to various allies
within the administration,
within the White House.
But the fact that Trump himself
was asking whether or not
the federal government
could seize voting machines
is really one of the first details
that we're learning about
this closed door
testimony in the Jack Smith January six
federal investigation.
Now, This is all happening in secret.
You know, witnesses go
in, they testify in private.
But, you know, our sources are telling us
a little bit,
giving us a little window
into what prosecutors
are asking in front of this grand jury.
And there are 22 tracks
to the Jack Smith investigation.
One is about the classified documents.
This is about
trying to steal the election,
trying to overturn
the election, obstruct the government
transfer of power in pieces like that.
What do we know about
sort of the context in that?
Absolutely.
And so, you know,
they've we know the witnesses have gone
in, Cuccinelli and Chad
Wolf have gone in and talked
about how they told Trump
and Rudy Giuliani,
who was obviously Trump's lawyer
at the time, that DHS couldn't
seize voting machines.
But then Robert O'Brien,
who was Trump's now
security adviser at the time,
has gone in and talk to prosecutors
about a meeting
that took place days
after Richard and Wolf warned Trump,
where the idea of seizing
voting machines came up again and Trump
didn't shoot it down.
So they're reading
a little bit of a sense
of what prosecutors are asking.
So that's a big deal, John.
Let's get some legal context.
If Donald Trump's in the room,
he's told
you do not have the authority to do this.
And he insists on doing it anyway.
Everything in a criminal case
comes down to intent.
And when you are
advised of something
that you're not allowed to
do, that speaks to your intent
to do that thing.
There are two possible crimes, conspiracy
to defraud the United States,
which, you know, he's investigating
and maybe false statements
made regarding some of this material.
And that kind of information
would touch on that directly.
It was clear from the president's
remarks last night,
former president's remarks last night.
He spent more time on Jack
Smith, mostly about the documents,
but more time on Jack Smith
than he did in New York.
What is this
new reporting tell you about what Mr.
Smith is trying to put together?
Well, I agree with Eliot on the intent,
but here the real devil's in the details.
I mean, it's
what they are saying about
Trump's reaction.
It's not enough just to ask the question,
can I see them?
There's got to be something there
that says
he doesn't care, that he hasn't lost.
He still wants to take
these ultra vires actions.
That's where the devil's going to be
is what really
are they getting him to say?
And he's very careful about that.
I mean, does the mob boss
think he may just be saying,
I just asked questions?
Fascinating.
No such high level officials.
Again, a lot of people.
To Trump's argument about witch hunt,
these are members of Trump's team
now being forced to testify
before the grand jury sat cold.
Very important reporting. Thank you all
It might be
months before
defendant Donald Trump is back in court
in that New York felony case.
In the meantime,
his goal, crystal clear rally the base,
turn his legal woes into political gain.
I never thought anything like this
could happen in America.
I never thought it could happen.
The only crime that I have committed
is to fearlessly
defend our nation
from those who seek to destroy it.
This fake case was brought only
to interfere
with the upcoming 2024 election,
and it should be dropped immediately.
Immediately
Even fierce
Trump Republican critics
do see an undeniable
short term political boost.
The question is
whether he can sustain it.
As as
you can see there, this case right now
parallels
the Republican nominating calendar.
Trump's legal filings are due
ten days or
so before the first Republican debate.
His next in-person
Manhattan court date is set for December.
That just before
the calendar turns to 2024
and the kickoff Iowa caucuses.
Joining me now to share their reporting
and their insights, CNN's Dana Bash.
Sunlen Kim of the Associated Press.
Jackie Kucinich of The Boston Globe
and Mario Parker of Bloomberg.
It is interesting
and you can put the calendar back
up there for a second.
Schedules and trial cases
sometimes change.
But right now,
motions being filed by the Trump team
over ten days or
so before the first Republican debate.
There will be more debates in the fall.
They've yet to be scheduled.
The prosecutors have to file a response.
He's due in court in December.
In February of the Iowa caucuses.
Is it possible?
Yes, he's winning now.
But how does the Trump
campaign sustain that he has gained
in Republican polls right now?
How do they sustain that
if you're back in court
through that season?
I mean, they usually don't
change their tactics very much.
So I think
this is about making him
the victim that he's standing up
for his people.
And it's all about
the the him being persecuted
for his views.
Now, the
question is whether his opponents
on the Republican side
start attacking him for this.
And we have not seen that
in a widespread way, in a cohesive way
quite yet.
But you haven't even seen the idea
they all attack brag.
They all attack the prosecution.
They say it's over the line.
That's pretty much a standard Republican.
They don't say.
But but he's not electable.
We don't want to do this.
We don't do.
But Newt Gingrich,
I think in this political saga
has it just right.
And Newt himself remembers
what it's like to be in the middle
of political storms.
We're back to Trump all the all Trump
all the time. Nothing makes him happier.
Now he'd like it
to be more positive than it is.
But if his choice
is between being totally ignored
or being in the middle of a firestorm,
he's in the middle of a firestorm.
And he's good at it.
That is a fact.
Even if you're out there
and you don't like Trump,
whether you're a Democrat or Republican,
an independent,
Trump knows how to manage a storm.
No, absolutely.
You're saying the Trump
ification of the GOP, right?
Where a case that ostensibly
he committed back in 2016 to help
his electability is actually coming back
to bite him in a way legally
But also powering him
through the primary right now
when he was at his weakness
in the last seven years.
And yet during the speech last night,
I was getting texts from Republicans
which essentially describe as this
because they were watching him
just lie conspiracy theories, chaos,
all the things that cost Republicans
to lose in 2018
for Trump and Republicans
to lose in 2020.
And then Republicans to underperform
in 2022
he claimed again 2020 election fraud.
He went after Hunter Biden
he claimed Biden
obstructed the classified documents
probe into him
he went after the Fulton County
district attorney went after
the special counsel Jack Smith.
He went after
the judge in the Manhattan case.
He went after the prosecutor in the case.
The chaos is what Republicans
worry about that
this strength is him as the nominee
and then screws them.
Forgive my language down the line.
Yeah.
And never mind
admitting more than once
that he took boxes from the White House
openly, openly, openly took boxes
from the White House.
You're exactly right.
In terms of the reaction from Republicans
that there is almost no moment
where the former president, now
current candidate has what, in a Swiss.
It is
it is a good political day
and it is twisted.
Anybody who goes in
and is arrested
and is in court
and has to say not
guilty is a good thing politically,
but that what it was for Donald Trump
at least that day can take that
and squander it.
And he
did that
with his grievance filled, rambling,
live filled speech
that he gave last night.
Imagine a world this is not me talking.
This is several Republicans
sending us unsolicited texts like you
in which he got up there and he said,
this is a tough day for me,
a tough day for my family.
I'm innocent.
We're going to keep fighting.
See you later.
And not what he did
but what he did was put out a fake
mug shot to raise money off it.
He goes, you see the room in Mar
a Lago there,
Don Junior, Mike Lindell,
Marjorie Taylor Greene.
This is a greatest hits of people
who still say
the 2020 election was stolen.
Who still say all the things
that Republicans believe if he's
the nominee again next time.
Right.
I mean, I was
watching his remarks last night
and it was really deja vu all over again
in terms of playing
the greatest hits of his grievances
and whatnot.
And I
am just really curious
to see how much
that support from his fellow
current and future
Republican primary challengers
will sustain itself.
Because you're right,
that calendar is really remarkable
at how
all the court
developments line up with the Republican
nominating process.
And I know that they are supportive now,
obviously concerned
about offending the Trump base of voters.
But I don't know how sustainable
that's going to be.
I mean, you're running
or considering running
for the presidential nomination
because you think you would be the best
candidate
against Donald Trump
and yet you are continuously
promoting him
and helping him in this process.
I know that obviously Ron
DeSantis has done
the little personal dig saying
I don't know anything about, you know,
making hush payments to a to a porn star.
And I think, you know,
the former Arkansas
governor, Asa
Hutchinson, has also talked about
not attacking the prosecutor.
Or respecting the rule of law,
but that's getting drowned out. Yeah.
And I think all you need to know
about how complicated and unsure
the ramifications of this
are is the sound of silence
from Democrats. Right.
Chuck Schumer,
senator from New York,
senior senator from New York,
put out a sort of a milquetoast statement
saying he hopes that he has a fair trial
and that's it.
Pretty much
no other Democrat has said
anything that tells you a lot
they want to stay away from this
and that Biden hasn't declared
he's running again yet.
Why would why would you
why would you, though,
if you have all of this turmoil going on
on the Republican side?
In an odd way,
the fact that it's months
now until the Trump team
has to file their motions,
if that calendar stands
again, perversely,
might help him politically,
because if you're one
of those Republicans,
you're looking for something
to grab on to, to turn and say, see,
we can't elect this guy again,
and you got to wait.
And that's the problem, right?
Just talking to Republicans
like Ron DeSantis,
what are you doing at this point?
I mean, you haven't taken any shots.
Nobody's standing up to him right now.
The field looks a little
weaker than most people expected.
And so Donald Trump is lapping it
off of this irony Chuck.
This this situation chock full of irony.
The chaos helps him with the base,
hurts him with everybody else.
We'll see how it plays.